Super Saiyan did in fact have for a
brief moment red eyes Okay well not
really uh it's complicated let me get
into it so back when the cooler movie
was in production the plan was for there
to be a Super Saiyan reveal much like
what had just taken place in the manga
and to help the anime staff with color
design so as not to have another ARA
Vegeta moment Toriyama pitched in and
provided a full color design for many of
the characters including Super Saiyan
Goku and he had red eyes in fact in the
original Japanese trailer for the movie
you can even see those red eyes in
action well okay barely but of course
that's not how things panned out in the
end why well likely because of Toriyama
doing a color chapter in the manga where
he was forced to really decide on Super
Saiyan's color design and then informed
the animation staff thereafter the way
the production timeline for both worked
this is very likely the case moral of
the story Super Saiyan was never meant
to have red eyes but it almost did